Elisany Silva towers above her sisters.
The 14-year-old measures in at six feet and nine inches...
...or just over two meters and she wants to be a model.
I think my size, my body which is very slim, my tiny waist,...
...everyone who sees me tells me I could either be a basketball player or a model.
But I'd rather be a model.
But life for the Brazilian teen in a poor beachside neighborhood in Braganza...
...is not without serious challenges.
Silva was forced to quit school because she's too tall to ride the bus...
...and constant headaches and muscle pain plague her.
Silva's mother Ana Maria Cruz noticed her daughter's rapid growth when she was 11 years old.
The doctors suspect I have a tumor in my pituitary gland...
...and suggest that I undergo a laser tomography, but I never got a chance to do it.
Silva's runway debut is scheduled for late September.
The teen's story has attracted a massive media attention and she's basking in the limelight.
Now I like to be a tall girl.
It calls people's attention.
Everyone looks at me, takes photos, films.
And with any luck, her modeling career could soar to amazing heights.
Tara Cleary, Reuters.